bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france votre syndic a été l'un des
premiers à tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
sur cette dangerosité présumée de ces
masques vous avez peut-être vous même
porter ces masques qu'est-ce que vous ou
vos collègues
ont-ils été gêné d'une manière ou d'une
autre nous n'avons pas eu de retour
effectivement de de gêne particulière
par rapport à nos collègues ça étant dès
lors que nous avons été informés de ces
deux substances qui peuvent être
dangereuses pour le corps humain bien
entendu nous avons saisi notre
administration nous avons évoqué ce
sujet en commission d'hygiène et de
sécurité au niveau ministériel est
effectivement comme d'ailleurs dans
l'ensemble de duras de la fonction
publique c'est le principe de précaution
qui s'applique et c'est à dire que ses
basques sont retirés pour l'usagé des
fonctionnaires pour l'instant il n'y a
pas de destruction puisque la seule
agence nationale de sécurité sanitaire a
été saisie des thèses des expertises
doivent être sont en cours d'ailleurs et
on est dans l'attenté des résultats de
ces de ses basques de leurs prix
vous dites donc il a eu une réaction
immédiate de la part de votre direction
dès lors que nous avons été informés
effectivement nous avons saisi notre
administration qui effectivement a
immédiatement je dirais stopper la
distribution de ces masques il faut
savoir que c'est une commande en fait
interministérielle dont le ministère de
l'intérieur a été en partie doté est en
tout cas dès lors que en tout cas les
informations ont été données et que
notre ami sastre ont été saisis sur ce
sujet les masques ont été retirés par
rapport à l' usage donc c'est vraiment
le principe de précaution qui s'applique
voilà ce que nous espérions parce que
quand même un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires de police aussi également
autre haut fonctionnaire est derrière
vous l'avez cité dans notre reportage
d'autres administrations ont été amenés
à utiliser ces masses qu'il n'y ait pas
de toxicité derrière qui déclenche des
petits qu'ils aient des séquelles plus
tard le principe de précaution
l'emportent donc aujourd'hui vous le
rappeler on attend désormais à l'avis de
l'agencé nationale de sécurité nationale
et r pardon sur la dangerosité de ces
masques est ce qu'au moment de leur
distribution vous auriez entendu le
principe de précaution dont se prévaut
aujourd'hui finalement pas de marque
plutôt que ces masques la cale regarde
que vous portez finalement sur cet
incident en fait ces masques ne
représente qu'une petite partie 1-2 du
volume global des masques distribués au
sein du ministère de l'intérieur
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya des masques
jetables chirurgicaux de type
chirurgicaux il ya ces masques delà de
cette marque
il y à d'autres masques lavables
d'autres marques et donc en fait c'est
vrai que dès lors qu'il y a dangerosité
en tout cas qui peut étre avérées ou pas
on n'est pas spécialiste et c'est pour
cette raison que je dire des tests sont
en cours et nous dirons effectivement si
la toxicité pour l'organisme ou pas et
si effectivement il ya de toxicité bien
sûr le retrait sera sera véritablement
étudié aujourd'hui on arrive plus ces
masques là vous en avez reçu d'autres en
échange et c'est ce que vous nous dites
finalement c'est ma cave de la marque
dim représenter un petit palais le sens
du stock plus large de masse que vous
avez reçus oui c'est certain on va en
tout cas c'est un c'est une partie
véritablement que ce nous nous avons des
basses que jetables des masques
chirurgicaux nous avons des basques la
vague mais d'autres marques également
qu'ils ont été distribués donc et
l'ensemble j'irai deux de ses marques
qui sont aujourd'hui contestée dans la
tente de résultats des tests en tout cas
n'avait pas et loin de là tous été
distribués donc on était on était en
phase de distribution justement de ces
basses et voilà le principe de
précaution qui s'applique en tout cas
est une bonne chose nous l'avions
réclamé l'administration l'a fait gérer
sans hésitation aucune
et c'est quand même la santé des
fonctionnaires de nos collègues
policiers et des fonctionnaires en
général puisqu'il ya également des
personnels de l'éducation nationale
d'autres administrations en tout cas qui
sont concernés merci beaucoup pour votre
réaction très clair secrétaire général
adjoint unsa police